hasta ahora ya hemos hablado de lo que
es el gradiente de una función para lo
cual necesitaríamos una función que
podremos decir que es de dos variables
para que todo sea más simple verdad por
ejemplo podríamos considerar la función
x cuadrada más ye cuadrada que esta
función es bastante amigable verdad
entonces en los últimos vídeos nosotros
dejamos un misterio sin resolver y
esencialmente por ejemplo aquí bueno
tenemos el gradiente de efe que se puede
calcular como el vector que tiene
entradas las derivadas parciales
derivada parcial de f respecto de x y la
derivada parcial de f con respecto de ye
verdad entonces por supuesto el
gradiente de la función puede tener
digamos más dimensiones si tuviéramos
más variables
digamos como en el espacio de entrada
verdad y bueno después vimos una digamos
un poco de intuición gráfica y vimos que
el gradiente era la dirección del
ascenso más producto pronunciado verdad
entonces por ejemplo si aquí tenemos
como siempre nuestro
a grama vamos a hacerlo más derechito
ahí lo tenemos digamos que este es
nuestro espacio de entrada aquí tenemos
la coordenada x coordenada y verdad y
por ejemplo si tenemos una función f en
realidad estamos pensando que este
espacio de entrada lo estamos
transformando verdad en nuestro espacio
de salidas que por ejemplo en este caso
sería la recta verdad entonces si
nosotros tenemos aquí un punto
cualquiera arbitrario digamos verdad
entonces podríamos fijarnos en todas las
direcciones posibles en las que podemos
movernos podríamos tener un montón de
direcciones posibles en las que
podríamos movernos y la pregunta aquí es
de todas estas direcciones en las que
podemos movernos cual resultaría digamos
cuál de esas direcciones resultaría ser
la que nos genera un crecimiento más
grande de nuestra función entonces por
ejemplo esta dirección a lo mejor aquí
y aquí es el punto en donde la función
manda a este punto amarillo verdad
entonces a lo mejor una dirección nos da
cierto aumento a lo mejor otra dirección
nos da un aumento mayor quizás otra
dirección nos da un aumento en esta
dirección no sería un de digamos sería
decreciente verdad en esa dirección
quizás nos da algo más negativo todavía
entonces la pregunta es cuál de estas
direcciones resulta en el crecimiento
mayor y si quieres pensarlo en términos
de gráficas podríamos fijarnos en la
gráfica de nuestra función verdad aquí
tenemos el campo gradiente todos estos
vectores se encuentran en el plano xy y
son gradientes verdad entonces si nos
fijamos desde abajo verdad quizás
podríamos ver porque cada uno de estos
puntos se mueve digamos en la dirección
que indica verdad que nos está diciendo
cómo subir digamos colina arriba en la
gráfica verdad lo más rápido que se
pueda si estuviéramos escalando una
montaña y quisiéramos llegar a la cima
lo más rápido posible
esto nos diría la dirección en la que
deberíamos movernos para ir lo más
rápido que se pueda y es por esto que le
llama
la dirección del ascenso más pronunciado
volviendo a esta parte cuando
recientemente yo vi este tema no no me
fue nada evidente la relación que existe
verdad porque porque sería de que este
vector es el vector gradiente indica la
mejor dirección y ahora que ya hemos
visto la derivada direccional puedo
darte un poco de intuición de por qué
esto es cierto así que en vez de
fijarnos en todas las direcciones
posibles
pensemos únicamente por ahora pensemos
únicamente en una dirección así que
vamos a quitar todo esto
pintar de nuevo nuestro espacio de
salidas que digamos ahí está pensemos en
un vector digamos tenemos este vector
vamos a llamarle el vector b este será
el vector b y para que todo esto sea
simple digamos que este vector es
unitario y también para que coincida con
nuestra digamos pendiente verdad cuando
hacemos el corte en una gráfica como
vimos en el vídeo anterior guardad y
entonces nosotros ya sabemos que la tasa
de cambio verdad a lo largo de esta
dirección cuando nos movemos en la
dirección de este vector ve la tasa de
cambio está dado por la derivada
direccional verdad la derivada
direccional en dirección del vector b de
nuestra función digamos evaluada en el
punto a coma b así que pensamos que este
punto de aquí es el punto a de verdad
esto está dado por la siguiente fórmula
es el gradiente de nuestra función
efe por supuesto evaluada
punto donde nos interesa así hacemos el
producto punto de este gradiente con
nuestro vector de verdad y hace algunos
vídeos vimos por qué es que esto
representa a la tasa de cambio en la
dirección del vector de verdad entonces
intuitivamente dijimos bueno si
consideramos un vector de digamos por
ejemplo el 12 podría ser cualquier otra
cosa verdad entonces el producto punto
nos dice o más bien este vector nos dice
que damos un paso en la dirección x y
dos pasos en la dirección y entonces si
queremos ver la tasa de cambio a lo
largo digamos moviéndonos en esta
dirección pues es razonable pensar que
será en la tasa de cambio una vez en la
dirección de la de la componente x y dos
veces la tasa de cambio en la dirección
de verdad entonces esto fue una idea
intuitiva que desarrollamos
anteriormente en otro vídeo verdad ahora
bien esta fórmula que tenemos aquí es la
que nos va a indicar
la dirección busca la verdad la
dirección del digamos del ascenso más
pronunciado verdad entonces por ejemplo
este vector d puede darnos alguna
digamos algún cambio digamos en esta
dirección pero si a lo mejor nosotros
consideramos otro vector digamos w
verdad entonces éste puede generarnos
otro tipo de cambio verdad entonces en
esencia lo que estamos haciendo es
buscar cuál nos maximiza la la derivada
direccional verdad es decir estamos
buscando el vector v verdad y este
vector tiene que tener tamaño uno tiene
que tener una longitud de uno que nos
maximiza la derivada direccional verdad
que se calcula como el gradiente de la
función evaluada en el punto de interés
haciéndole el producto punto con nuestro
vector entonces estamos variando todos
estos vectores b que tengan magnitud 1 y
queremos maximizar este valor que es la
derivada direccional y para ver esto hay
que
pensar en lo que representa el producto
punto verdad del producto punto entonces
digamos que tendremos por aquí nuestro
gradiente de la función digamos que
apunta más o menos así puede ser van
suficientemente grande verdad y digamos
que aquí tenemos nuestro vector de
entonces vamos a pintar a nuestro vector
b y este vector de recordemos que es
unitario es decir tiene longitud 1 bien
y en esencial nuestro vector de que es
este que tenemos aquí entonces este
producto punto que tenemos entre el
gradiente y el vector b representa la
proyección que hay de este vector ve
hacia este vector que es el gradiente de
f entonces en esencia vamos a proyectar
de forma perpendicular a nuestro vector
b sobre el gradiente df y lo que
obtenemos como distancia verdad hacia
esa proyección eso es lo que representa
el producto punto entonces sólo por por
dar
ejemplo digamos que esto es 0.7 y por
supuesto que esta longitud tiene que ser
menor a la de nuestro vector que es una
verdad claramente entonces luego lo que
vamos a hacer es multiplicar esto por la
longitud del gradiente de nuestra
función entonces digamos que tenemos
aquí la longitud de nuestro vector y
digamos que su longitud no se es 2
verdad por ejemplo entonces la
interpretación de este producto punto
será simplemente el producto de la
longitud de la proyección que sería 0.7
y lo multiplicamos por la longitud de
nuestro vector verdad que era 2 entonces
la pregunta es de todos los vectores de
tamaño unitario cuando se puede
maximizar este valor entonces por
ejemplo podríamos pensar quizás en otro
vector que también tenga tamaño unitario
pero que esté ligeramente rotado hacia
donde se encuentra el vector verde
verdad ya lo mejor aquí
nuestra proyección sea de 0.75 verdad
entonces sí sí digamos tomamos el vector
unitario que apunta justo en esta
dirección del gradiente entonces estamos
pensando en este vector unitario verdad
entonces la proyección la longitud de la
proyección coincide con la longitud de
este vector que de hecho vale 1 verdad y
si a lo mejor no estás muy seguro de
todo lo que hemos estado diciendo con
respecto al producto punto entonces
puedes buscar los vídeos que tenemos
aquí en kant academy de este tema verdad
pero al menos aquí ya es mucho más fácil
convencerse de que justo lo que va a
maximizar este producto punto es justo
cuando tenemos el vector unitario que
apunta en la misma dirección del
gradiente entonces este máximo se
alcanza justo cuando tomamos como vector
a el gradiente de nuestra función por
supuesto siempre evaluado en el punto de
interés pero tenemos que dividir
y su magnitud verdad para que sea un
vector unitario entonces esta es la
respuesta este es el vector que maximiza
la derivada direccional verdad es decir
es el vector del ascenso más pronunciado
en resumen lo que maximiza este producto
punto verdad de digamos de una cosa con
vectores unitarios es justamente el
vector que apunta en la dirección de
este vector inicial verdad y esto
también nos va a dar una interpretación
de lo que es la magnitud de nuestro
gradiente entonces digamos que todo este
vector es el vector w este vector w es
unitario verdad entonces si nosotros
calculamos la derivada direccional en la
dirección del vector w verdad de nuestra
función esto será igual al gradiente de
la función y hacemos el producto punto
con el vector wv verdad si nosotros
sustituimos quien es w tendremos el
gradiente de f multiplicado con el
gradiente de f dividido
la magnitud del gradiente de y por
supuesto aquí he estado metiendo en
donde estamos evaluando y la verdad es
que lo estoy metiendo por flojo verdad
en realidad el gradiente de nuestra
función siempre va evaluada en siempre
va evaluado en el punto a de verdad por
aquí vamos a omitir lo sólo para no
hacer más complicado esto el producto
punto del gradiente df con el gradiente
de f nos da justamente la norma o el o
la magnitud del gradiente de f elevado
al cuadrado y esto lo dividimos entre la
magnitud del gradiente de f entonces
esto se simplifica verdad porque esto ya
podemos quitarlo y quitamos el exponente
2 así que en esencia lo que hemos
obtenido es que la tasa a la que crece
la función al moverse en la dirección
del gradiente está dado justamente por
la magnitud del gradiente df así que
este vector parece ser como como mágico
verdad hace un montón de cosas primero
es la herramienta necesaria que nos
y calcular derivadas direccionales y con
esto encontrar las tasas de crecimiento
en una dirección también nos dice que es
la dirección del ascenso más pronunciado
y como consecuencia de esto su magnitud
indica la tasa de cambio en la dirección
del ascenso más pronunciado así que el
gradiente es parte fundamental de las
funciones multivariable de valores
escalares y de hecho es la extensión de
la derivada en cualquier sentido que
quieras extender el concepto de derivada